hello guys my name is Asher know and it
is that time of year again well third
time this year really but it is time for
another lot I'm dare so those of you who
don't know what a lot and areas or lewd
and array or however you want to
pronounce it really I just don't care
anyway let them there that's how i
pronounce it and we're spending way too
much time talking appreciation but
basically lovin dare is a 48-hour game
programming competition or a 72-hour
game jam in which you have that amount
of time 48 hours usually to make a game
from scratch and look at this spelling i
just noticed just tragic really anyway
mmm the loudoun dear actually starts
kind of two moro it says december
eleventh although it's going to start
december 12 in my time zone which is in
australia in melbourne but basically i
have all their anyway anyone who's doing
the competition has 48 hours to make a
game from scratch based on the theme
that gets released as you can see the
theme voting is in progress the thing
gets released when the competition
starts ok i do this uh I do like them
dead pretty often in fact most of the
people following my channel probably
know that so so I'm excited to be in
this one last time I actually didn't
last time was the first love and death
at I hadn't finished since like since I
actually I missed one recently as well
but usually I do them but last time
unfortunately I got sick like halfway
through it and I got like a favor and
everything and I just didn't I just
wanted to relax and not worry about
finishing my game so I kind of dropped
out halfway through but last time I
actually started using unity for the
first time ever to make a game because
because I you know I mean you know me I
like using new technologies every time I
look at latum dare as a thing to kind of
as like 48 hours to learn something new
really ok so that's kind of why I did
that but anyway they didn't really work
out so this time i actually just don't
really have a particular technology or
framework or engine or library that i
want to use ok so what i'm actually
going to do is a bit something a bit
different i'm actually going to say that
i'm going to do latum down i'm going to
make my game in
whatever you choose okay all you have to
do is leave a comment below being like
hey I think you should make your game
using Sparky which is my c++ game engine
or I think you should make a game from
scratch in java using no libraries or i
think that you should use unity or I
think you should use unreal or I think
that you should write it in I don't know
assembly or something not that one
please but um regardless of that I'm
actually just going to leave this up to
you guys so whatever you want to see
just leave a comment below if you see
someone who has left a comment like for
example unity and you also want me to
use unity to make a game just upload
that comment okay you can leave your own
comment as well but just make sure you
get those upvotes going so that we can
I'll basically pick the top comment and
whatever that is is what I will use ok
so it's pretty exciting I hope that you
guys don't pick something absolutely
ridiculous i'm sure you won't because if
you guys do pick some energy that's
probably not gonna happen but within a
reason i'm actually i want to use
whatever you guys say this time because
i'm just i'm keen to really i just don't
have a plan right I just don't have
something that that I specifically want
to use okay and if it if it ends up
being something like Sparky odds are
i'll probably actually spend a bit of
time developing the engine a bit because
it's actually in a bit of a broken state
right now so I'd almost rather not use
it but anyway we'll see what happens so
anyway leave a comment below with what
you want me to use and i will be using
that the whole thing will be streamed
live on twitch.tv for that show no okay
which is my twitch livestream page right
i'll be streaming the whole thing here
okay pretty simple now if you want to
know when i go live okay there are two
ways there's actually this countdown
which it says that i'm currently offline
and i actually haven't updated the the
the time to next stream but i would
bookmark this page load other channel or
maybe even set it as your homepage if
you're that cool and then essentially
closer to the competition what I
actually know what time I'll go live
this will display a countdown in like
hours minutes and seconds to when I'll
actually go live so that that way it
works like all times
right but possibly even better is if you
actually follow me on twitter i recently
had 3,000 followers which is pretty
awesome but um i usually tweet out stuff
here right so i will actually like if I
know what's going on or if I'm running
late or something like that I'll just
dislike this is almost like a status
right that's what it's really supposed
to be just me being like oh hey i'm
running a bit late or hey I'm live
streaming right now here's a link so
it's a really good place to stay up to
date with pretty much everything okay
now unfortunately my weekend is looking
pretty busy okay particularly Saturday
so it's supposed to start at Saturday on
at one o'clock in the afternoon so 1
p.m. on saturday is when a lot embarr
starts this time in melbourne australia
so i actually may be busy at around 1 45
i have to go and run an errand and
actually see a movie that i was kind of
part of a little bit but anyway the
point is that's I shouldn't have said
that that's anyway point is mmm i'll be
a bit busy so i'm not sure what time i
will actually be able to start streaming
so unfortunately this might be one of
those times where I just start I
actually only start love them they're
like three or four hours into the
competition usually I've started it as
soon as the like thin goes out as soon
as the as soon as the actual competition
starts I'm always there i'm always live
streaming and I'm I just begin working
straight away but this time
unfortunately may look like I'm going to
start a few hours into the actual
competition which is a shame but on the
other hand I don't really want to I
don't really want to be like sorry
friends I'm not going to be able to make
it so if you know what I mean I kind of
just like I want to do both but it's a
bit difficult so what I'm saying is I'm
not exactly sure when I'll start
streaming I'll definitely will be doing
I've got my entice Sundays free as well
so I'll at least be streaming the entire
Sunday but um not sure what will happen
on saturday if you again follow my
twitter stream then you will actually
see me being like
like an hour away or whatever and I'll
also probably comment on what i think of
the theme and all that stuff so it's a
really good place to set up today
because again I'm just not sure what
will happen but anyway I'm looking
forward to it I hope you all are I hope
that you all will either do let them
down or watch me duel item dare and and
we can mix them let you know like
thousands of us can potentially make
some awesome games this weekend so
anyway I will see you guys then and of
course also happy birthday me goodbye